now let's bring in one of the uh 40
united states senators who
either wasn't invited or didn't accept
the invitation from the great state of
south carolina
senator tim scott how are you i'm doing
well congressman i hope you're doing
well
am thank you um it would hurt my
feelings to think that you were not
invited to that meeting were
were you invited and declined or are you
in the 40 that
that didn't get invited well they must
have hurt your feelings because i looked
through in the mail and i haven't found
that invitation yet so i assume
that it was not sent i am not one of the
ones that they need in order to get to
the 10. i think you make a very good
point
earlier in the show when you ask uh
what's the magic number to get things
done in the senate
the number 60 and 40 of us certainly
were not invited
well let me ask you this senator um if
you were to state
the republican position the the
conservative position
on covet 19 and a relief package what is
it what does the party believe
is appropriate in terms of a stimulus
package
well trey i think one of the things we
should recognize is number one
over fy 2020 this country spent 6.5
trillion dollars trillion dollars
overall
over four trillion dollars on coveted
relief
in december we approved another 900
billion dollars
and less than 20 of those dollars have
been spent
the question is what's the hurry we
don't even
know what happened with the december
900 billion dollars and so what we have
to do now
is take a step back and find out how to
effectively manage this
virus and i would say that perhaps we're
already there
but we won't know because we haven't
spent all the resources deployed
to help america recover from this global
pandemic and until we do that
it is way too early to negotiate
a two trillion dollar package or a
trillion dollar package
when a 900 billion dollar package that
we approved
has not been spent
now hang on a second senator i got to
stop you there
that was a revolutionary thought process
that you just had
wait and see whether or not the money
worked
before you appropriate more money is
that the revolutionary thought that you
just espoused on television
see if the other one works and then
we'll come in and plus
it up absolutely i mean in south
carolina
you don't spend any money you don't have
and you certainly don't spend it before
the money you already spent
has been spent i know that's a lot of
spending but at the end of the day
we should not move forward until we
understand
and appreciate how the 900 billion
dollars
for instance trey 80 billion plus was
the reopen schools
have they reopened how do we measure
that well there's a lock that comes off
the door
and the door opens kids walk in let's
just use common sense
to decide where we are and is that good
enough
all right senator i want to ask you
about one of your old colleagues or
senator from california kamala harris
she appeared to me
over the weekend to be putting pressure
on joe manchin and kirsten cinema
you know joe manchin at kirsten cinema i
don't think they're going to be
susceptible to pressure from kamala
harris but maybe i'm wrong
well i i think you're right especially
when you start having the vice president
talk about
uh destroying coal jobs in west virginia
and suggesting that the thing they
should do is to go find landmines
number one the one of the reasons why
america thinks of dc as a swamp
is too many politicians talk about
things they've never done
be a coal miner and also refer to things
they would never do
sweep for minds we should thank god that
we have a military that went forward in
looking for ways to to take care of the
land mines
but why would you send a coal miner
there who's really good at
coal mining but has never been uh in
landmines that's just
ridiculous hyperbole hyperbole
coming from the vice president and it's
just uh it's sad to hear
but good news is uh those two centrist
democrats that you talked about
they're not easy to persuade by using
that type
of hyperbole yeah my guess
is that the coal miners in west virginia
do not need
employment advice from a progressive
lawyer from san francisco but that's
just my guess
here i want to ask you this when i look
and think about the future of the
republican party
when i when i look for it i see you
i see your face uh is there something
that you would like
to tell us about your own future because
when i think about the future of the
party i see people like tim scott
what do you see well there's no doubt
that
that my future starts right now with
2022 and i'm looking forward to running
for reelection if you want to support
that reelection you can go to
votetimscott.com and make a contribution
but more importantly
just joking their trade but here's the
truth the bottom line is that
i like most americans believe that
there's dignity in all work we believe
that hard work pays off i like most
americans
believe that my value comes from god
not from government we believe in hand
ups not hand outs we believe that we
should help those who
cannot help themselves not those who
will not help themselves
i am a person who understands redemption
because i've been redeemed
that is the story of america and that's
a story that we should all
be motivated to share with our fellow
americans
america is a good place i believe
in the goodness of this nation and if we
sell that because it's true america will
be far better off tomorrow
than it is today senator thank you for
coming on i hope you are one of the
messengers that carries that message uh
in 2022 as you say timscott.com you
sound like lindsey graham he always came
on and said stand with lindsay.com but
you only said it once
good luck in 2020 20
we'll see what 2024 holds for you thank
you
next